[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs
bienvenue sous l'arbre à palabre je ne
sais pas si vous connaissez lab a pas là
dans leur village sous l'arbre à palabre
on discute de sujets délicats et ce jour
nous allons parler d'un sujet délicat
nous voulons parler du sexe le sexe en
afrique parler du sexe fait un sujet
tabou mais en plus ce dont nous voulons
parler c'est que le parent et l'enfant
parle de la sexualité
sacrilège on ne parle pas de sexe avec
ses enfants en a fait juste parce que
nous n'avons pas appris à le faire dans
nos cultures
mais aujourd'hui pouvons nous continuer
en tant que parent à nous taire nos
adolescents et jeunes je veux parler de
nos enfants qui ont à partir de 10 ans
auront l'information puisque
l'information est disponible maintenant
l'information est disponible à flot à
foison
si nous n'y prenons garde nos enfants
auront l'information mais souvent de la
plus mauvaise manière
d'autres se chargeront de leur donner
l'information est plus d'informations
qui ne leur faut c'est pour cela que
nous pensons fermement qu'il est temps
aux parents africains à apprendre à
parler sexualité et spanghero positive
avec leurs enfants
les deux fonctions principales du sexe
c'est le plaisir c'est donner la vie est
il possible à un enfant de 12 ans
d'entendre de la bouche de son père
ma fille le cers produits procure du
plaisir
pourtant il le faut si elle entendue de
la bouche de son père ce sera du déjà
entendu
du déjà connu
laissez moi vous conter l'histoire de
deux adolescents
l'une à présent et à 13 ans elle avait
déjà des relations sexuelles depuis
trois ans avec l'ami intime de son père
et qui de plus la menacer de mort le
jour elle va livrer le secret pour les
parents notre fille est bien connu rien
du sexe je ne vous dis pas la fin de
l'histoire
un autre
un collègue qui avait que cela quand il
avait 6 ans il a été surpris par sa mère
emplettes dérangement dans le creux
d'une brique six ans parce que la bonne
qui lui a appris à faire ça est déjà
partie de la maison et le pauvre garçon
n'arrivait plus à maîtriser cette
sélection et ses envies mais à qui le
dire voulons-nous continuer à monter
parce que nous sommes africains et qu'on
ne parle pas du sexe votre enfant en a
entendu plus on a vécu plus avec le net
l'information incomplète l'information
erronée est mortelle votre enfant a le
plus confiance en vous quand qui compte
mais il veut pouvoir aborder avec vous
deux sujets qui l'intéressent et l'une
des sujets qui intéressent l'adolescent
ses compères les changements qui
interviennent dans son corps est ce que
votre petite vie de 12 ans peut vous
dire je suis amoureuse moment oui moi
j'ai choisi que à 14 ans comme monfils
aura 14 ans je vais lui parler du sujet
délicat alors le matin dès 14 ans je
suis allé m'asseoir à son jeu lui a
chanté son happy birthday to you et puis
je lui ai dit écoute mon fils
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de sujets
importants parce que tu viens d'avoir 14
ans
aucun moment on y va et voilà je veux te
dis que tu as remarqué que depuis un
moment ta voix n'est plus la même
tu vois que le torrent c'est plus
développés mais il ya encore que le même
qui va te donner plus d'ici là tu peux
prouver comment t'es tu as mouillé ton
lit c'est pas grave c'est le
développement physiologique normal et
tout j'ai fini de dérouler mon disque
haut de mon fils me dit maman tu es en
retard
aïe aïe aïe que vais-je dit encore ah
oui je suis dans le tas oui mais j'ai
déjà eu ce truc deux fois quoi oui et
comment tu as fait la première fois j'ai
pensé que je ré pipi au lit je me suis
levé j'ai rapidement lavé le drame la
deuxième fois j'en ai parlé avec mes
camarades à l'école ils m'ont mis sur la
table m ont fait de grands banquiers
déjà un homme aimant vraiment alors j'ai
respirer profondément je dis ok allez
bon répertoire
j'ai dit c'est vrai mon fils en plus ce
que tes amis on dit est vrai tu es
devenu un homme mais inconnue tue la
signification maman oui je dis que c'est
vrai que tu es devenu un homme
à partir d'aujourd'hui si tu as des
relations sexuelles avec une fille
j'ai table de la mettre enceinte eux
alors j'ai trouvé l'occasion pour
continuer ma conversation pour dire que
j'ai une croyance religieuse c'est très
bon on vous a dit tantôt que je suis une
chrétienne je suis même via ce n'est pas
mon église je vais passer le message de
pourquoi il est important
de préserver son corps je dois faire
comprendre à l'enfant que son sexe est
une partie importante de précieuses qui
n'appartient qu'à lui et qui doit être
utilisé au bon moment pour jouir du
plaisir qui est dans la sexualité
n'oubliez pas quand on je vous ai dit
que les deux fonction du sexe c'est du
plaisir et donner la vie mais là où se
trouve la vie se trouvent la mort et
c'est pour cela que nous devons parler
avec nos enfants parce que une sexualité
hasardeuse peut conduire à des maladies
vous en savez quelque chose puisque je
vois ici avec moi des jeunes une
sexualité hasardeuse peut conduire à la
mort quand j'ai eu une grossesse non
désirée et que je m'en vais avorté je
suis en train de creuser ma part je
n'aurai plus une sécurité dans ma santé
reproductive pour aborder la deuxième
fonction du sexe abordée alors la
sexualité à nos enfants
c'est l'erreur de capable de dire non
mon corps m'appartient à moi c'est les
rendre capables de ne pas subir les
violences les abus c'est les rend
capables à pouvoir bénéficier d'une
sexualité saine et responsable
nous devons apprendre à le faire
mais qu'est ce que je suis en train de
dire aux mains vais aborder ce sujet
avec mon enfant moi maman papa africain
africain je n'ai pas appris à faire ça
que dois je commencer que dois-je dire
voilà pourquoi il est important
d'apprendre aujourd'hui les 160
disponibles et là aux start up
c'est un défi qui est lancé nous pouvons
que y ait des applications où les gens
peuvent aller chercher des ressources
pour donner l'éducation sexuelle à leurs
enfants mais vous qui est déjà là vous
êtes heureux d'être là parce que nous
allons vous donner les bruits de cette
éducation
alors quand je dis qu'on commençait il
faut commencer quand il est encore
enfant
si vous l'avez pas appris à parler de
sujets d'autres sujets que de dire va
faire ci va faire ça que de donner des
ordres avec votre enfant vous n'allez
pas pouvoir parler avec l'adolescent
parce que l'adolescence consacre la
rupture entre le parent et l'enfant
donc c'est depuis qu'il est enfant que
vous devez comprendre commencé à lui
dire telle ou telle partie de ton corps
servent à ça et donner l'éducation
adapté à son âge et évoluer
progressivement
donc il ne faut pas attendre que
l'enfant soit grand avant de vouloir
aborder un sujet délicat tabou avec lui
comment le faire ok je viens aujourd'hui
on doit parler de cette diète à soit là
non c'est pas possible
nous ne pouvons pas appeler l'enfant
comme ça pour les adolescents il faut
saisir les occasions saisir les
opportunités
nous avons regardé un film ensemble il y
à un sujet
saisissez l'opportunité pour parler du
sexe avec votre enfant
saisissez toute opportunité pour ouvrir
le débat mais par les abords de ce sujet
avec vos enfants parce que aujourd'hui
ils sont
là ces îles sont menacées de toutes
parts et si vous voulez parler à
l'adolescent parlez-lui avec respect
l'adolescent veut qu'on le respecte déjà
parlé lui seul valoriser le pm interdit
de poser des questions ne l'arrêté pas
quand il place des mots choquants
si vous n'avez pas une réponse à sa
question promet de lui de revenir pour
en reparler mais faites-le après avoir
cherché la réponse de toute façon de
toutes les façons aujourd'hui la
mondialisation est irréversible
l'éducation est indispensable
l'éducation à la sexualité est
indispensable par les parents les ong le
gouvernement ne feront que arrosée ce
que vous avez déjà se met à la maison et
vous c'est vous qui allez donner
l'equilibre en faisant passer maintenant
vos valeurs pendant cette éducation
si vous ne vous chargez pas de
l'éducation sexuelle de vos enfants
d'autres s'en chargent voulez-vous avoir
des adultes équilibré voulez-vous avoir
des adultes épanouis voulons avoir une
jeunesse qui contribuent pleinement au
développement de l'afrique
parlons du sexe avec nos enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]